Thó không所以 sao?
Anh tử bah đẹp cũng tạo lời
lyrics chuyện n
nó là chân gèy tọng tiên
thì nó vẫn không hứt thử
Với lại hôm nay sẳng là ngày chứ
dok hẹn Thó
mình muốn trải nha vậy luôn
Đây về mong nữa cũng có thất là lâu rồi
Điều thay
Được rồi ya
Đây hẹn có người dưới tư của như vậy
Nói tụi bây giờ đi
Tụi bây giờ là dưới tụi bây giờ
Tụi bây giờ khoảng 5, sông người
có người đăng cho tôi đóng
trông địa
thì nguyде tụi bây giờ
tụi bây giờ đúng s contour
Hôm nay có thể làm gì vậy?
Hôm nay có thể làm gì?
Mày không có thể điên.
Trời ơi, cô sẽ phải đoạn.
Cô dạ đã có mọi mấy nạn của bây giờ.
Chào đối gặp.
Cô đoạn nhận.
Bây giờ mấy nạn và bây giờ vẻ nó làm gì?
Cô dạ.
Chào đối gặp.
Bây giờ có thể đoạn.
Thật hệ.
Cái giọng không thích tệ hợp, có thể giọng hợp.
Bây giờ chúng ta sẽ giọng hợp.
Cái giọng hợp là một cái gì đó.
Mình nhau mốt, mình nhau sửa khách nhiệm của thành phố.
Mối lắm nằm rồi.
Cái gái ngon đàn ngày đầu tiên.
Bắc cứu cho những mình hợp giọng điều cho một chờ.
Chứ trải nghiệm mấy cho rồi đâu.
Đần đầu tiên nó đi, mấy cho.
Thấy rất thích.
Cái là hay lếu mà ai và tiền đi làm việc tất cứ là đi lại.
Thật điện nắm.
Không bị tắc kẹt sè.
và chỉ vì nó là tính ở đây từ sự tiền đến một mỗi tiền.
Rá rất là rẻ, sau mê rất là sẵn.